You know, you know, I never thought I'd go to war with a city.
I never thought I'd go to war with the city, but I'm at war with the city, baby.
I talked about Albuquerque on Twitter and they,
and then I, and guess what? Now they, and dude,
they're back.
Social media is shedding more light on his comment.
Chris Delia performed earlier.
Dude, another segment,
another segment,
two segments, two segments, too many.
I'm a correspondent at this point,
dude, they came back and did another segment. Last episode,
I talked about Albuquerque and they did a segment on me about how I quote
unquote bash them and this
afterwards, they said my name right in the first one shade.
They didn't say it right in the second one. You know what it is?
Social media is shedding more light on his comment.
Chris Delia performed earlier this month at the chemo theater afterwards,
he took to Twitter saying, quote, I've been to some blank holes, but Holy blank,
you make Jacksonville look like paradise.
Many new Mexicans criticized him on social media. Well,
a couple of days after our story aired, Sally responded to the outcry saying,
couldn't believe the response.
I was there for eight hours in my podcast on their news segment, Weiss.
I'm sure it's fine.
How could you get upset about somebody saying something.
What's that now he still hasn't revealed an exact reason for not liking
Albuquerque, but he did poke fun at chemo.
Theater's name does the best part and said our buildings are short Albuquerque,
but he did poke fun at chemo theater's name and said, our buildings are short.
Dude. The newscaster said that,
ah,
food, the newscaster said,
I said that the buildings are short. I said,
you have to crouch down into him, dude, what the,
man? Hey man,
by the way, there was another child shot.
By the way, there was a murder. They murdered 70 people in Albuquerque.
Unbelievable dude,
pro Albuquerque turned out to be my favorite city in the U S dude,
just because of their, they clap back. They have a clap back effect.
I told my buddy about this and he was saying that, uh, you know,
cause Aaron Paul shot our Aaron's a buddy of mine from a breaking bad.
And that Aaron Paul shot, uh, they shot breaking bad,
breaking bad over in Albuquerque. And the reason why, you know,
that is because anytime you step foot in Albuquerque,
everything about breaking bad is plastered all over.
So, uh, did,
he said something about Albuquerque that wasn't favorable one time and they made
a whole segment about him. So it made me feel less special.
So that's that's okay. That's okay. That's okay.
But they make it a big deal about it. And that's hilarious to me, dude.
So Albuquerque shout out to you, dude.
You're becoming my favorite city in the U S just because of the segments, man,
this just in about Albuquerque, uh,
James Woods is shooting a movie here and he just said it was too cold.
We check into some locals here to see about how they feel about James Woods
saying that it's too cold. I don't know. I mean, you know, it's just,
it's it's it depends really what, what, um, when you come,
the seasons are different and obviously it's going to be colder in January and
February than it is going to be in, um, July,
you know, maybe if you came in the summer, uh, it would have been, um,
it would have been warmer, but you know,
if he's going to come during the winter, uh, obviously it's going to be, uh,
colder. So I don't know, maybe they should shoot movies in the store.
James Woods was not available for comment,
but he's took to Twitter bashing liberals.
Um, so yeah, dude, anyway, I I'm, I, you know,
loving it. I don't know whatever they,
they mispronounced my name on the second segment,
but on the first segment that got it right. Hey, Hey, Albuquerque.
Um, so whatever.